yeah we're thinking he's back again
again following a production delay of
approximately two years amidst
complications brought on by the pandemic
John Wick chapter 4 is finally on the
way to theaters slated for release in
March 2023 and the latest footage from
the movie is driving fans of the series
wild this next installment in the John
Wick franchise will pick up soon after
the events of its third chapter which
marked a significant shift in the
relationship between Keanu Reeves Title
Character and the powerful high table
the organization that rules over the
secret society of Assassins of which
he's apart in August of 2022 with the
film's release less than a year Away
director Chad stachelski suggested that
the sky's the limit for the John Wick
franchise when it comes to future movies
according to the filmmaker the
possibility that Jon could go to space
one day is even on the table in some
series that would be a jump the shark
moment in this one it'd probably just be
cool finally the official trailer for
John Wick chapter 4 premiered on
November 10th while it doesn't happen to
include a sequence set in outer space
this extended preview nevertheless
suggests a both unpredictable and
extremely exciting Adventure on the
horizon are we right about that John
yeah
following the release of the full
trailer many reactions from fans put a
spotlight on the franchise's surprising
longevity many agree that John Wick has
yet to wear out its welcome despite
laying more convoluted mythology onto
the series with each new installment on
YouTube a number of commenters shared
their delight at the fact that four
films in the John Wick series is still
dramatically compelling one user wrote
John Wick is one of the only franchises
I can never get tired of they always
find a way to keep it fresh receiving
more than 1500 likes from like-minded
viewers another YouTube commenter left
their own reply on the trailer saying
these are the only movies that can keep
being made without being too tacky
seemingly in response to comments like
these another user praised the John Wick
fan base for its widespread sense of
excitement and general lack of
negativity meanwhile on the primary
movie discussion subreddit a number of
users expressed similar sentiments one
user simply commented that they'll
continue watching John Wick movies for
as long as they come out another
compared the John Wick series to the
long-running Marvel movies which still
packs some entertaining punch despite
being a fixture in theaters for years on
Twitter too plenty of fans shared their
thoughts on the full trailer not
surprisingly many of the posters agreed
with the consensus that the franchise
has yet to decline in quality one
Twitter user wrote that they plan on
seeing chapter 4 without watching any
trailers for the film beforehand putting
their trust in the high quality of the
series thus far meanwhile another user
posted four screenshots from the chapter
4 trailer with the caption it goes
without saying but man the John Wick
films just keep getting more Sumptuous
with each entry pop culture writer
Richard Newby praised the chapter 4
trailer on Twitter as well saying that
like many others he has yet to grow
tired of the John Wick franchise
YouTuber Brett Coleman even went so far
as to joke sometimes I wonder if the
promise of more John Wick movies is the
only thing holding the fabric of this
country together while it's possible
that John Wick chapter 4 could
disappoint some longtime fans responses
thus farf are so overwhelmingly positive
we're not sure how it could it seems
increasingly likely that this next entry
in the series won't just clear the high
bar set by its predecessors it might
just raise it
Last Words Winston just have fun out
there John Wick chapter 4 premieres in
theaters on March 24 2023
[Music]